eyes and remain standing to receive the
president the rector and the honorary
doctorate recipient
i'm pleased to invite professor haim
haines director of the university to
enter the hall
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i would now like to invite the president
of the university professor daniel
chamovitz to enter the hall
[Music]
and now ladies and gentlemen it's my
great pleasure to invite the honorary
doctorate recipient her excellency dr
ursula fondo leo president of the
european commission please
[Music]
timely reseated ladies and gentlemen
i would like to call upon the president
of ben gurion university of the negev
professor daniel chamovitz to address
the assembly
well how exciting
good morning honored guests
members of the diplomatic corps
colleagues
and of course our honoree here
excellently dr ursula van der laan
president of the european commission
our university proudly bears the name of
david ben-gurion
and we strive daily to meet the
standards set by this great man
to adhere to his values and to realize
his vision
from our new unique vantage point in the
negative desert we aspire to hold up his
values
we believe that anything is possible and
that curiosity openness and flexibility
are key to creating and imparting
knowledge
this has been our privilege and duty
every single day in the 52 years since
the establishment of the university
in the words of david ben-gurion our
country is small
the only greatness that awaits us
inherent in our essence is the greatness
of the spirit
science the knowledge of the world and
the universe the discovery of nature and
of being in which we will arise and
ascend
we bestow the doctorate honors causa
upon individuals who exemplify the
characteristics that we wish up to hold
as an inspiration to our students and as
role models for our own community of
scientists scholars and supporters
individuals for whom excellence is not a
buzzword but rather an innate value
your acceptance of an honorary degree
from bgu reflects that honor back on our
institution and what it stands for
providing a mirror within which we hope
to see a bit of ourselves
and when i look in this mirror
at your myriad of accomplishments your
priorities i am pleased to see some of
the directions that we as a university
have also committed to
your road map for green transition to
battleground climate change is perfectly
aligned with the new goldman sonnenfeld
school of sustainability and climate
change
for over 50 years we have been learning
how to live in our desert
and now the world comes to us to learn
from our experience
and your long-term commitment to women's
rights gay marriage and an inclusive
democratic society is built into the dna
of our university which sees its mission
as building a shared academic society
that uses higher education as a tool for
societal transformation
we humbly realize that you do not need
us to not acknowledge your
accomplishments and i thank you for your
allowing us to honor you
i wonder if david ben-gurion could have
envisioned this gathering
this ceremony
i dare say that he would sit back and
say
i told you so
because in 1959 david ben-gurion told
israel's first ambassador to the eec
as he was preparing for his mission
that the european countries allies and
former enemies alike had embarked on
their own road of economic cooperation
to political unity
their future economic well-being he said
and social progress required the
establishment of a closely knit
community which would become a central
force in world affairs with brussels at
the center of the community
how fitting then that david ben-gurion
university house houses the simone vile
research center the seoul jean-mones
center of excellence in israel dedicated
to deepening and enhancing knowledge
of contemporary political
and social developments in europe
as well as promoting awareness of the
ever-growing importance of the european
union
simon val a holocaust survivor who went
to be the first woman to be president of
the european parliament was a firm
believer in european integration as a
way of guaranteeing peace
and she was a great friend of our
university
receiving an honorary doctorate in
thousand and ten
dear president vanderlaam
by accepting this degree from our
institution you are continuing this line
from simon vale further strengthening
our commitment to promoting euro-israel
relations and european studies and
cementing our position as a national
center of excellence in this crucial
field
your actions and accomplishments are an
inspiration to all of us here today
i have no doubt that david ben-gurion
also had you in mind in his remarks from
1950
some of us are pioneers
some are able to motivate the people
and a few
a small few
go before the people to show them the
way
thank you for showing us the way
[Applause]
thank you professor shamowitz we now
continue on to the conferment of the
honorary doctoral degree
ladies and gentlemen honored guests
before our doctorate recipient is called
to the podium a short film will be shown
highlighting her achievements
[Music]
in raising my daughters
i have always told them there's no such
thing as jobs for men
and jobs for women
women and men
in the jobs market
should enjoy the very same rights and
opportunities
when i was elected president of the
european commission i promised
that my commission would be the first
gender balanced one in our history
so everything can change with a bit of
perseverance you have a very strong
wonderful partner in your husband
because i have seven children how did
you two work it out well to be honest
the first 15 years of our marriage
he made a career and my career the trunk
trunks shrink shrink shrink over and
over and at the very end i was a
part-time working mom with seven
children and he was a professor for
medicine
the typical story and then i was
appointed minister for family affairs
and all of a sudden i had no time
anymore so he he had to take over his
duties as a father so if you share
the positive benefit and the burden
among the two of you you have an
enormous amount of strength that results
from that
[Music]
we will fight anti-semitism at all
levels
we will never allow the holocaust to be
denied
we will fight with all our strength
against discrimination
racism
and exclusion and we want to see and we
will fight for a normal life for jews in
europe you can rely on us
jewish culture has so much to teach us
and european jews have contributed
immensely
to the making of modern europe and to
the shaping of our european identity
you have been a light unto the nations
fixing climate change
calls for everyone's action every day
protecting
the environment protecting
the climate has a lot to do with
innovation we will need clean innovative
technologies that's what we're looking
into
and if the world does that the demand
for these technologies will be enormous
therefore it's such a business case and
business opportunity for doing this
development research in
innovation into clean technologies
you can count on me as i know i can
count on you
it is a time for change
let's make it happen together
[Music]
[Applause]
the university honors her excellency dr
ursula fonder leon president of the
european commission and confers upon her
an honorary doctorate i invite the
president and the rector to please come
forward
i now ask
president fond de leon to join them
[Applause]
the scroll reads as follows
the senate and the executive committee
of the ben gurion university of the
negev hereby resolve
to honor dr ursula fonder lane
in recognition of an exceptional states
woman president of the european
commission
guiding the european union towards a
promising future by promoting democracy
peace and unity among its members
in acknowledgement of her inspiring
leadership confidently steering the
union through upheavals and storms
including during the current war on the
continent
appreciation for the extraordinary
skills she has applied in service of the
public throughout multiple cabinet
appointments in germany including as
federal minister of defense minister of
family affairs and youth and minister of
labor and social affairs
with sincere regard for her
contributions to germany's security and
social justice
and her efforts on behalf of its women
children and youth in particular
in gratitude to a true friend and ally
for her uncompromising efforts to
eradicate anti-semitism
and ensure the well-being of jews
throughout europe as well as her
commitment to enhancing the standing of
the state of israel and deepening its
ties with the eu
and with great esteem for her dedication
to environmental protection and economic
growth and for her dauntless
perseverance in advancing equal rights
and opportunities for all people and for
future generations by conferring upon
her the degree of doctor philosophy
honoris causa with all the rights and
privileges pertaining there too
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and now the president of the university
will present a gift to president fond de
leon
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you professor shamavist and
professor haynes
it's now my honor to invite president
fonte leia into the podium to address
the audience
[Applause]
thank you very much mazel tov
president ramowicz professor
hames
professor pardo professor mizhachi
excellence is dear faculty dear students
shalom
i feel honored and humbled
by this recognition
and the fact that the honorary doctorate
comes from this prestigious institution
the bengal yon university negev
has a very special meaning for me
this isn't only because the list of your
doctors honoris causa is truly
impressive
from simon vale as we've seen to it's a
cabin
there's also more personal reason
for me
i am a european woman
of german nationality
and not longer than 80 years ago
millions of jewish people were murdered
by germans
in the greatest crime of all human
history
we in germany take historical and
enduring responsibility
for this inhuman disruption of
civilization
it is an indelible stain
on my country's conscience
which we must never
and will never forget
so it seems like a miracle
that a german like me
is welcomed
and honored
here in the state of israel
as a friend among friends
only a few generations after the shore
but it is no miracle
my being here
is the consequence of a choice
made by the state of israel
and by one man above all
the great david ben-gurion
it was he
who took the first historic step towards
reconciliation with the germans
he believed that the best way
to honor the victim's memory was to
build a better future
it is also to the credit of david
ben-gurion
that my country
looked the victims of our crimes
in the eyes for the first time
the young german democracy grows grew
stronger
because of its developing friendship
with the new state of israel
we faced our guilt
and our responsibility
and all this
while the european project was taking
its first steps
the very reason
why the european union was founded
lies in two simple words
never
again
a new generation of germans was raised
with that premise
including myself
and i can say without reservation
that i would not be here today
if it wasn't for david ben-gurion
[Applause]
as long as i can think i was convinced
of two very simple facts first there is
no europe without european jews
and second
europe and israel are bound to be
friends and allies
because the history of europe
is the history of the jewish people
europe is simon vale and hana arendt
europe is mala
and kafka
and freud
europe is the values of the talmud
the jewish sense of personal
responsibility
of justice
and of solidarity
today almost 80 years after the shoah
jewish life in europe is thriving again
countries like portugal and austria are
rediscovering their jewish heritage
i see it in brussels too
as the little film showed just a few
months ago
i had the honor to light the chanukah
menorah in the heart
of the european quarter
what an experience
and yet
european jewish life is also embattled
and endangered
anti-semitism has not disappeared
it still poisons our societies
and anti-semitic attacks happen today in
europe
it is a new threat
but it is the same old evil
every new generation
must take responsibility
so that the past does not return
and this is why i have put the fight
against anti-semitism and fostering
jewish life in europe at the core
of the european commission's agenda
our democracy flourishes
if jewish life in europe flourishes too
throughout the centuries
the jewish people have been
a light unto the nations
and they shall be
a light unto europe for many centuries
ahead
we have more in common than the
geography would suggest our shared
culture and values have created a deep
connection between europe and israel
and i'm not just talking about israel's
participation in the eurovision stone
cost contest and the champions league
the strongest bond we share is our
belief in democracy
and in democratic values
and here again wenger young's legacy is
enduring
ben goryon believed that israel's
strength depends on its democratic
institutions
and only
in a democracy would citizens feel
compelled
to take responsibility
for their common home
and he is so right
thanks to this conviction the state of
israel has flourished ever since
you have become a prosperous nation even
in the most challenging of circumstances
and in a complicated region
championed women's rights in unlikely
times
and golda meir's leadership inspired
women across the world
me as a young girl too
your freedom of thought has turned a
small country of just a few million
into a global trail blazer for science
and innovation
and democracy has strengthened our
special bond of friendship through the
decades
today more than ever before democracies
like europe and israel should come
closer together
not because our democracies are perfect
they are not
no democracy is
democracies often
offer the environment in which diverse
societies can thrive and they are
challenged like never before
and we can help each other to overcome
these challenges
so together we can get one step closer
to the ideals of our founding fathers
and mothers
ladies and gentlemen today i would like
to focus briefly on three of these
challenges
the first is a challenge stemming from
autocracies
the second is climate change
and the third is democratic backsliding
the most direct of these challenges
comes from authoritarian regimes outside
our borders
and indeed
what we witness in these days
russia's aggression of ukraine is a war
against democracy itself
it is a war against the idea
that the people of ukraine
can take sovereign decisions
about their own future
year after year
ukraine's diverse and vibrant civil
society has pushed for positive change
and has strengthened the country's
democratic institutions
and this is exactly what the kremlin is
fighting against
it couldn't be more symbolic
that the first russian bombs in kiev
fell right by the gate of a holocaust
memorial
and that the russian propaganda
is built on the abominable
rhetoric
of de-nazification
against a democratic ukraine
we see with great worry
that the age-old threat of scapegoating
the jewish people in times of war
and i know that israel has helped
ukraine with tons of humanitarian aid
and a field hospital
and you have welcomed tens of thousands
of ukrainian refugees to your land
in a war against democracy
we all have a stake
and for us europeans
the stake couldn't be higher
the kremlin has used our dependency on
russian fossil fuels to blackmail us
and since the beginning of the war
russia has deliberately cut off its gas
supplies to poland to bulgaria to
finland to dutch companies to danish
companies
in retaliation of our support of ukraine
but the kremlin's behavior only
strengthened our resolve
to break free of our dependency of
russian fossil fuels
for instance we are now exploring ways
to step up step up our energy
cooperation with israel
we have two major projects in
preparation
the world's longest and deepest
underwater power cable connecting israel
with cyprus and greece
and this will over time be
electrification from renewable energies
that's where the investment has to go
into you have an abundance of these
natural resources to produce renewable
energy
and the second is a gas and clean
hydrogen pipeline in the eastern
mediterranean
this is an investment in both europe's
and israel's energy security
and this infrastructure
will also contribute to decarbonizing
our energy mix
it is a great example of democracy
sticking together
not only in times of conflict but mostly
to fight this huge enemy we have and
that is climate change
this is the big looming crisis in the
background
and we have to take all our knowledge
are all our engineering and
entrepreneurial spirit we have
to innovate to bring about
the innovative technologies
to work to fight climate change to make
this world a better place and to hand it
over to our children with still a spring
a summer a fall and winter to experience
climate change is this great challenge
that our democracies are fighting
and no one understands that better than
you
here in the negev
david ben-gurion believed that here in
the negev
israel's creativity and its pioneering
spirit would be tested
as he said
he always spoke about the duty to make
the desert bloom
and that is exactly what you've done
ever since
that have listened to what i was told
about this university
as we can see in your school of
sustainability and climate change
i marvel
at how you're
testing new building materials that can
withstand the desert heat
nature based solutions
and how you have managed to adapt food
crops to the desert climate
with the looming food crisis we know
that these will be the technologies that
will make the difference
whether we will master the food crisis
and over time
have independent production in the
vulnerable countries or not
you have with all that
quite literally made the desert bloom
and today the solution that you've been
researching for decades can change the
life
of millions across the world a few weeks
ago i was in davos
where president hartsuk spoke exactly
about that
it was an important speech
which resonated well beyond our region
and president had so called for new
alliance and i quote
to shape not only a new
middle east
but a renewable middle east a middle
east that thrives as a global hub
of sustainable solutions in food water
and health
and as a source of solar energy to
europe asia and africa
end of quote
i couldn't agree more
with this vision
for decades europe and israel have
cooperated closely on science and
innovation
just last december israel joined the
eu's massive research and innovation
program it's called horizon europe
and has a budget of almost 100 billion
euros
it is now time
to put our corporation
at the service
of the ones who need it most and at the
service of fighting climate change
and ladies and gentlemen
the first and final challenge to
democracy that i would like to address
is perhaps the most subtle one
this challenge is within
it is the risk of backsliding that all
our democracies face
democracy is necessarily a work in
progress
it must be exercised and renewed each
and every day
each of our democracies is different
and unique
but ultimately
democracy in all its forms comes down to
the same thing
as ben gurion always said
he said the outstanding attribute of
democracy is not
government for the people
it is government by the people
democracy gives people a voice
it gives them the power
to change things
with their vote
in democracies we even fight for other
people's freedom
to disagree with us
the freedom to speak your mind
the freedom to change your mind
the freedom to be yourself
so that if you are different
from the majority
you are always equal before the law
and this is what binds democracies
together
the recognition
that we are all different
yet
all equal
today
this is challenged in many ways
societies are becoming more fragmented
public debate has become more polarized
and it gets harder and harder
to focus on the common good
from the attacks against the rule of law
and free press and free research in some
parts of europe
to minority rights and coexistence here
in the region
democracies must have room for everyone
including those who think differently
who believe differently
or who come from a different region
israel is a vibrant democracy
its resilience is admired worldwide
israel's society is incredibly diverse
for example i was impressed to learn
that over 800 students from the bedouin
community are studying here at ben
gurion
israel is a small slice of land
where people of all faith
and born on all continents
live together
families who have lived here for
generations and families who have just
arrived
diversity
can be an immense
strength
yet the path towards peaceful
coexistence
is long
and democracy is never accomplished once
and for all
this is also true for the european union
like other democracies europe faces
external threats ranging from
disinformation
and interference in our elections
as well as challenges from within our
societies
ranging from nationalism to xenophobia
from revisionism
to anti-semitism
we must strengthen our democracies
and our way of life in democratic ways
every single day
we must nurture our openness and our
diversity
we must defend the freedom of our media
the independence of our judges the
equality of all people before the law
keeping democracy in good health is hard
work
but it's worthwhile work
imperfect thou it might be
this is the best thing about democracy
autocrats
cannot admit mistakes
democracies
can always improve and correct because
we
the people
can always make it better
because we the people
are the ultimate guardians of democracy
ladies and gentlemen
on each one of the challenges that i
have addressed today
i feel my generation's
responsibility
to leave you a better world
than the one we inherited
but it is you
the young generation that i see here in
the room it is you
each and everyone
who will write the next chapter
it is your energy
your empathy
it is your knowledge
your tolerance
it is your hard work
your love
that will shape the world and
democracies of tomorrow and that makes
me confident
because your generation is also the most
educated
the most climate conscious
and the most
open-minded the world has ever seen
ben goryon said in the early days of the
state of israel
independence does not only mean
liberation from a foreign yoke
independence has a positive meaning
and that is the most important the
positive content of independent
independence means responsibility
it's independence of the heart
and it is independence of the will
end of quote
long live europe am
israel high
thank you
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
thank you president fond de leon for
that important and moving address
i now invite professor heim haims
director of the university to deliver
his greetings
her excellency dr ursula van der leyen
president of the european commission
distinguished ambassadors and diplomats
faculty and students ladies and
gentlemen
madam president
your eloquent remarks almost make my
remarks superfluous but there are things
that are worth repeating so please
please bear with me
israel is a country that was established
and developed mainly by immigrants who
came from the arab world
north africa
and of course europe
indeed it has been said that
historically geographically religiously
and even culturally israel is from
europe but not in europe
the history of the jewish people in the
zionist movement as an intellectual and
political force that gave birth to the
modern state of israel are without doubt
deeply interwoven with the histories and
cultures of eastern and central europe
and as professor [ __ ] vinery warns
anyone who fails to understand this will
be unable to grasp much of the structure
and nature of israeli society
its politics and culture both on the
practical and symbolic level
in this regard a reflection made by
israel's first prime minister david
ben-gurion after whom our university is
named in a letter to the lebanese
egyptian diplomat and historian george
antonias antonios explains the close
bond between israel and europe
although we are an eastern people we
have become a european people and we
wish to return to the land of israel
only in the geographical sense
our aim is to create a european culture
here and we are at any rate linked to
the major cultural force in the world as
long as the cultural basis in this part
of the world does not change
end of quote
and indeed the european union is
israel's economic educational cultural
and in many respects political interland
israel's engagement with the european
economic community the eec began even
before the 1957 founding treaty of rome
entered into force
in may 1957 less than two months after
it was signed the treaty was already
translated into hebrew and published in
israel
in fact in mid-1957 there were those in
the israeli establishment who worked
hard to develop israel's initial
relationship with the eec
into a full economic and political
membership
such was israel's enthusiasm to get
closer to united europe that the young
shimon peres then director general of
the israeli minister of defense
and special envoy of prime minister
david benguyon he met secretly with
jean-monet one of the founding fathers
of the european union in order to
explore the idea of israeli economic and
political accession to the eec
in april 1958 israel became the third
country in the world after greece and
the usa to request the establishment of
a diplomatic mission accredited to the
ec and in february 1959
israel was the fourth country in the
world to establish full diplomatic
relations with the european communities
in october 1995 israel and the european
union concluded a research and
development agreement through which
israel became the first non-european
country to be fully associated with the
union's research programs which are
known today as horizon europe
since 1996
israeli academia in general and
ben-gurion university of the negev in
particular have been among the most
active members in successive calls for
research projects and they are important
sources of innovation in both basic and
market-oriented research conducted in
the european research area
today indeed the european union is
israel's largest source of research
funding
as a historian whose work focuses on
inter-religious encounters i feel
obligated on this special occasion to
recall
the often violent and discriminatory
attitude including pogroms and
expulsions towards the jews and european
soul over the past millennia culminating
with the shahad the holocaust the topic
that i know and we've seen and heard has
informed our honoraries political career
and activism over the years
while the foundation of the state of
israel and the establishment of close
relations with the european union has
had in remain a positive effect
anti-semitism is again on the rise and
has become intertwined with anti-israel
sentiment
while on the one hand our relationship
is characterized by a strong and
ever-increasing network of economic
educational research and development
cultural and personal ties and a will to
be included as part of the european
integration project
on the other hand some israelis are
suspicious of the union's policies and
are and are untrusting of europe's
intentions towards the middle east
be that as it may and as you so
eloquently said
in a rapidly changing world with global
challenges such as climate change and
war
we need to stand strong together
and protect our common democratic values
which are so crucial for vibrant and
functioning civil societies
we are proud to have a simon vale
research center for contemporary urine
studies which coordinates the national
gen monet center of excellence along
with the
monet chain in european integration
studies held by professor sharon pardo
which spearheads our efforts to become
even more integrated with our academic
partners in europe
as you take leave from us
and continue with your busy schedule
i would like to thank you for doing us
the great honor of accepting the title
of dr honoris causa from our university
with your distinguished record of
leadership creativity vision and
excellence and your ongoing work for the
betterment of germany europe israel and
the world you are a role model for us
all
in the words of proverbs chapter 31
verse 29
many women do noble things but you
surpass them all
thank you again
[Applause]
thank you very much professor haynes
ladies and gentlemen this concludes our
very special event today please remain
seated until the recipient of the
honorary doctorate pres and president
shemovitz and rector haims have left the
senate hall i'd like to thank you all
for joining us this morning at ben
gurion university of the negev shalom to
you all
[Applause]
[Music]
um